so deadpool joined the ranks of
fortnight today I couldn't wait for our
usual map change meetup so today there
is a special episode 20 awesome details
in the Deadpool update do me a favor
think about using code Adam aru if this
was entertaining let's do this
[Music]
let's get ourself over to the yachts but
before we do a quick look at how we
unlock Deadpool in the game after
completing the challenges we step into a
phone booth for the ultimate superhero
change welcome to the game Deadpool now
let's find out what's at the yacht and
look right away the map has been updated
to include Wade Wilson sketch he drew
all by himself this continues on the
boat where you can find many Deadpool
comic images drawn by the hero himself
some are more epic than of this there
are also some pieces of famous art
recreated just for Deadpool with this
image which is a pointillism painting
made to mimic Joshua by the way
pointillism is where the artist only
uses a dabbing motion not that kind of
dab to make the picture yes I used to be
an art teacher don't judge me
this image here is another you'll likely
recognize it's Deadpool's version of the
scream by Edvard Monk and the last piece
of art is this completed in a cubist
style kind of like Picasso Oh in fact
there is one mark just inside the vault
see it for yourself how debonair is that
in the main room of the yacht is the
Statue of Midas but now he's been
changed his face has been replaced with
that of the Merc with a mouth and the
globe is now a disco ball for a dance
party below complete with music there's
now a bar here and there's two ice
sculptures here can you name which
characters they are in the game I'll be
skulking around in the comments to see
who gets it right
now let's look at the exterior of the
yacht and all the lighting and color
changes and of course that balloon
that's added but also did you note that
the umbrellas and parasols here are now
Deadpool umbrellas and look at the
helipad landing Bay the H is gone and
another Deadpool logo replaces it nicely
done whilst here is a really good one at
the front of the ship is none other than
dead pulls pants blowing in the wind for
off to sea gotta love it walking inside
the ship from the front deck is a taco
takeaway complete with chimichangas
Deadpool's favorite meal but I'm not too
sure about that price forty five dollars
is this a good deal people from America
there's another one of these round the
back two on the top deck of the ship is
an office slush bedroom first let's look
at the PC here we can find Deadpool's
note from his hiding place which depicts
his design for the battle bus and of
course now you've seen it in game it
looks great inside the cabinet next to
this are the one and only chimichangas
in pride of place for all to see real
works of art out of interest does
anybody actually like those have you
tried them in real life as this is a
bedroom we have a wonderful bearskin rug
and now take in those sheets the
Deadpool red with the logo yet again and
there's even a pair of your dad's
underwear here too disgusting they're a
little Brown to me maybe it's the light
Deadpool also tried to get a fireplace
up here but ultimately decided on a TV
set playing a roaring fire on repeat
just as good as the real thing if you
ask me next that's going to the bathroom
where Deadpool has revolutionized toilet
entertainment he set up a gaming system
and TV to allow us to play and poop at
the same time he's giving us the future
right here extra point for the pink
console it looks good let's go to the
back of the ship now and to this beauty
Deadpool swimming float is indeed a
unicorn it had to be didn't it he's got
taste after all you've got to admit that
around they got you'll also notice
graffiti such as Deadpool's placed
grenade loco and unicorns so many
unicorns and there's others too which
seem to change every few hours in-game
which is cool a quick note that if you
visit the jacuzzi there is more evidence
of Deadpool's junk
[Music]
now here's the biggest update to notice
a part of the yacht has been destroyed
and Deadpool is preparing for a little
cannon warfare but get the detail here
the cat litter trays are where the
cannonballs are kept but I don't think
these are machine made cannonballs they
look more like capped made cannon balls
if you know what I mean
and finally the gym has been converted
into Deadpool streaming set up he wants
to be the next ninja a full green screen
setup a new microphone a
top-of-the-range pc and a sock I wonder
where the other one is what would
Deadpool use socks for in fact don't
answer that
oh also check out the streamer chair
it's perfect
Deadpool also brings with him new emotes
and this glider Wow but for me this
update will forever be remembered for
this emote I absolutely loved this we
need to get 100 people having a race on
these bikes are you up for it people
let's make this happen
so there we have it as quick as I can 20
mini updates to fortnight with the
Deadpool update thank you so much for
your time there's no leg and roll call
in this episode but they will return
next time and will feature those people
who have used cold a damaru
in the shop this week thank you so much
thanks for your time for tonight family
enjoy the update I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade been a pleasure see
ya
[Music]
[Applause]